luxembourg it's a nation which sits in
an important location between the french
german and dutch-speaking worlds
it's also not a very large country with
a very small population
especially when compared to the major
nations and kingdoms which have flanked
it throughout its life
this raises an obvious question why does
luxembourg
exist and why wasn't it incorporated
into its larger neighbors
so luxembourg has been geographically
important since the middle ages back
when it was a duchy and a part of the
holy roman empire as of 1475 luxembourg
was
in a union with the duchy of burgundy
and it was ruled by a man called charles
the bold whom the king of france was not
a fan of due to charles's immense
influence there
in 1477 charles did the french king as
solid and died and it took a whole six
seconds for france to pounce and take
these lands to protect the remainder
charles's soleil mary was married to the
future holy roman emperor maximilian
habsburg
the remaining areas were consolidated
and luxembourg was incorporated into
what's called the habsburg netherlands
these remained under the direct control
of the holy roman emperor until the 16th
century when charles v abdicated the
throne giving them to spain
it wasn't long until the dutch decided
that this arrangement wasn't for them
and so off they went
leaving luxembourg as a part of the
remaining spanish netherlands in the
17th century
war with france saw luxembourg shrink
again and after the war of the spanish
succession it got handed over to austria
and it remained with austria until the
french revolution and its subsequent
incorporation into the first french
republic in 1795.
in the following two decades there was a
lot of war a lot of napoleon the holy
roman empire was dissolved and when the
dust settled
luxembourg's future was decided by the
victors at the congress of vienna
here several things happened to
luxembourg first it came under the rule
of william the first the king of the
brand new united kingdom
of the netherlands and entered into a
personal union with it second it lost
this territory to prussia
third it was brought into the german
confederation the sort of successor to
the holy roman empire which gave it a
sort of mixed constitution
with the nation being ran by william's
dutch administrators and defended or
occupied by prussian troops
and fourth to make up for all of this
the duchy of luxembourg became the grand
duchy of luxembourg because that way
william couldn't complain
now it wasn't long until the united
kingdom of the netherlands broke up with
belgium leaving and taking this massive
chunk of luxembourg with it giving it
its modern borders
it stayed under the control of the dutch
king who soon found himself in serious
financial problems to the rescue came
napoleon iii who in 1867 offered him a
bunch of cash for luxembourg which he
accepted
now otto von bismarck the chancellor of
the north german confederation
objected to prevent war britain and
russia arbitrated and came up with the
solution
this saw luxembourg remain independent
and further declare itself to be forever
neutral
it would remain under the control of the
dutch monarchy and it was also warded
that north german troops would withdraw
and in return berlin would get extra
economic concessions
luxembourg would continue to be ruled by
the dutch monarchy until wilhelmina took
the throne in 1890. the grand duchy
didn't permit for women in its line of
succession so
it went to adolf of nassau this state of
now independent neutrality remained
until 1914 when german troops invaded
and world war one
after the war the anton didn't really
know what to do with luxembourg except
for the belgians who really wanted to
annex it
the french said no when the remaining
members reaffirm luxembourgish
neutrality in 1920 which would last a
whopping 20 years
this time when the germans came knocking
for a second time luxembourg wasn't just
occupied but also incorporated into
germany itself
this of course wouldn't last because
germany lost the second world war and
luxembourg was restored and it would
remain independent to this day
although it would renounce its permanent
neutrality and became a member of nato
and the european economic community
shortly afterwards
and that is how luxembourg still exists
i hope you enjoyed this episode and a
special thanks to my patrons
james bissonette the pastry section
danny maloney marvin cassell kelly
moneymaker rob waterhouse john bisquez
mo james castaneda aaron the white
jordan longley marcus asner
gustav swan jerry lamdin john bailey
calling castleman rasheed ali spinning
three plates field oinkoink
maggie patzkowski david silverman izzy
lexi schwinn robert wetzel skye
chappelle spencer lightfoot and winston
caywood